Farrah's Jackson is already stepping out
following her hospitalization I don't
really expect anyone else understand on
Saturday afternoon
Paris was seen out in Universal City
with boyfriend Gabriel Glenn following
an incident just hours earlier where
police and ambulances responded to a
call involving an attempted suicide
around Paris's home the patient was then
transported to a hospital a source told
ET after the incident that Paris
suffered an accident at her home that
required medical treatment but she is
currently resting at home and doing fine
Paris then slammed reporting alleging
she made an attempt on her life tweeting
you youth Myers in response the news
comes after tumultuous few weeks for the
Jackson family Michael would come to our
house a lot
Paris's father the late Michael Jackson
has been in the news following the
release of the HBO documentary leaving
Neverland which alleges the popstar
sexually abused underage boys Michael
and I would take walks around my
neighborhood just talking and walking
and would be at nighttime
of course so he can sort of hide the 20
year old responded to the documentary
release saying there's nothing I can say
that hasn't already been said in regards
to defense family to me is a feeling and
again with expectations we honor him in
our own way
adding I'm just trying to get everyone
to chill out and go with the flow be
mellow and think about the bigger
picture
[Music]